7, the average number of times
a woman goes back to the man that abused her.
And the average number of times the world fails her with phrases like,
I don't believe you, or at least he didn't hit you.
7, the average number of times a woman returns to hell
because instead of trying to understand her,
we condemn her for escaping.
Because instead of asking questions,
we ask her to stay silent in the name of keeping the peace.
Seven times she has to learn that people don't take sides,
that speaking out against his lies won't open people's eyes.
And the number of times she learns to dismiss her experience
because the rest of the world isn't brave enough to see it.
Seven times there's a chance she doesn't get to try again.
Seven times
she goes back to the place she should be praised for leaving.
And seven times
she has to fight for support when she's fighting just to stand.
Seven times
we teach her to return instead of teaching ourselves how to save her.
we teach abusers that their actions don't have consequences.
Because seven times we'd rather side with them than admit that
the reason a woman returns to the man she should see as a threat
is because instead of stepping in to protect her,
we try to stay out of it.
Instead of understanding the battle she fought to walk out that door,
we tell her the war wasn't Real seven times.